This is the final installment of the beaker
ball balance problem.
So if you haven’t seen the first part, you
should probably watch that now.
The link is in the description.
Now assuming you have seen it, you know that
the balance tips towards the hanging acrylic
ball when weighed against a beaker with a
submerged ping pong ball.
But what would happen if, instead of tethering
the ping pong ball to the base of the beaker,
it was instead submerged by my finger.
I posed this question in the last video and
you responded with thousands of comments.
Thirteen percent of you thought that the acrylic
ball beaker would be heavier.
Twenty-nine percent thought the ping pong
And 54 percent of you thought that they would
be balanced.
So now let’s see what actually happens in
three, two, one.
Perfectly balanced.
But why is this the case?
Well, just as in the previous experiment,
both balls displaced the same amount of water
and so they experienced the same upward buoyant
force equal to the weight of water they displace.
Therefore, there are equal and opposite downward
forces on the water, making both beakers heavier
by this amount.
And our answer could stop here.
But if you are wondering why this result is
different from the previous case, consider
that in the first part, the downward force
on the ping pong ball side was counteracted
by the upward tension in the string.
But not any more, because there is no string.
Instead, the downward force from my hand is
equal to the buoyant force minus the weight
of the ping pong ball.
So that overall both beakers get heavier by
the same amount.
It is just the weight of water displaced by
the ping pong ball or the acrylic ball because
it has the same volume.
I hope you enjoyed this experiment.
If you have got another way of explaining
this, please let me know in the comments.